using metal shears she cuts out the
shape
[Music]
the artist peels off the plastic liner
that has protected the copper revealing
the glossy untarnished surface
[Music]
she now places the copper above a bag
full of small pellets and pounds it
using the nylon mallet this process
gives the copper an aged hammered
texture
she gives some areas on the other side
the same treatment the hammering also
pulls out the profile of the piece using
a marker the artist draws a line about
1/3 of an inch in from the edge
she marks dots onto this newly defined
border spacing them evenly apart
she then punches holes through all the
dots using the lever operated drill
press she cuts out the space between the
holes and this process creates separate
tabs for each hole the artisan now bends
back to tabs following the marked line
the application of a clear powder coat
prevents tarnishing after a few hours
the palm strands are now sufficiently
softened she retrieves the strands from
the hot water soap and sets them aside
the artist returns to the copper
centerpiece and begins to weave starting
with rattan reeds that have also soaked
to make them more pliable she pulls the
reeds through the tabs that enter
crosses them so that they fan out in two
directions
she then braids cotton string against
the center piece this creates a neat and
sturdy border all the way around she
alternates rows of palm and rattan
fibres the different textures add visual
interest to the basketry sculpture it
will take two months to complete this
work
[Music]
when the basketry work is done the
artist takes the piece outside and
airbrushes them with acrylic paint
she sometimes relies on a metal template
to more easily to find the paint border
it's the finishing touch to the basketry
sculpture and now it's up to the public
but understand the story that the artist
has woven
[Music]